(Upbeat Music)
(Music Cuts Out)
One of Us (In Flashback)
(Upbeat Music Continues)
I think this is in focus.
I want to go attack
Jake from Vsauce who just moved in
across the street,
but I don't know where Carmichael is
so I'm gonna go find him.
Is Carmichael in here?
Wren: I came looking for you.
Vsauce is at their office
right now,
right?
They don't have batteries for
their remotes,
so Jake texted me, he's like
"Hey can you bring us some batteries?"
We'll bring them batteries
over their dead bodies!
(Laughing, yelling, and nerf gun noises)
Jake: (Chuckles) Hello. Oh! You have a GoPro on it!
Welcome to the neighborhood!
Thank you!
Ah! Come here! Good to see you guys!
Oh! Good to see -- Let me hug you
Good to see you!
This is the only reason I moved next to you guys
so I could take batteries.
Well thank you!
Welcome to the giant empty space that is
the Vsauce office.
Cameraman: Have you showed anyone this yet?
No, this is the first.
I haven't even shown
the Vsauce viewers yet.
You've not even announced that you've
moved into an office at all.
No, not yet.
So thanks, Corridor Digital
for ruining that for me.
There's a lot we gotta do
basically this side of the office is gonna be a studio
Oh! I think it's the Time Warner Cable man.
Hello?
That's disgusting.
Yeah that dude's nasty.
He must
never know.
Niko: No you're doing perfect,
don't change that.
(Music fading in)
(Music)
Niko: Yeah!
He's stealing second base
but there's no - (giberish)
Cut
So you're gonna shoot all my stuff
and then move on to 'D' stuff?
We're probably gonna go back and forth.
Back and forth? Cool.
Yeah
We'll get me walking off from there
Let's get a shot through the fence
It's like it's just a wide angle
where you just see
me walking off and passing him
and that could be like the bystander angle.
Ready?
One
Are you ready?
Three
Two
One
Action!
Keeping him in total shade like that
makes it so intense.
(Wren Laughing)
(Exhales)
That was not pleasant.
(Dog whimper)
(Dog bark)
Obie help!
Don't just stand there.
Whoa!
An infared-
Spencer: So we can see right now
Jake: Oooh!
Spencer: The ceiling
Jake: is hot!
Spencer: is 110 degrees
Jake: That is a hot ceiling.
This is the coolest thing
that I didn't know about,
but now I do.
Okay
here's - here's an interesting fact
so right here behind this wall
Jake: Mmhmm
You can see that there's a pillar
Jake: Yeah
Spencer: behind that wall
Wren: Oh that's cool!
You can even see like the studs in the wall.
Jake: We're almost at X-Ray Vision.
Spencer: That's a misconception.
Thermal does not give you X-Ray vision.
Jake: But I can see studs!
Spencer: Yes, but that's because there's a temperature difference.
Jake: But it's because I can see through--
But, I mean, if we're being,
you know,
really pedantic about it,
I feel like that's kind of
a little bit of X-Ray.
I'm seeing through the wall.
So I added a bunch of nerf guns
to my Amazon wish list.
Wren: Oh my god
So it's gonna be my like "office supply wishlist"
(Wren and Spencer Laughing)
Jake: A whole bunch of--
Spencer: I mean, they are tax writables
Jake: I think so
Spencer: Yeah!
It's like, we need them.
But I love the reviews that people have on Amazon about them
they're like "Oh this one fires at like
this r-- like rate per minute" it's like all this stuff.
Carmichael: And then you can mod them
Jake: Yeah!
Carmichael: Hey Wren!
Jake: Wren?
Can you Assassin's Creed yourself up the building?
You want me to climb it?
Jake: The pipe.
Carmichael: Yeah, in fact, we challenge you.
Jake: I bet you 10 dollars worth of Taco Bell gift cards
that you can't make it up there.
Wren: Dude, that's such a deal!
Jake: That is a deal! That's like a month's worth of food!
(Laughter)
Carmichael: Keep going!
Carmichael: The challenge
Jake: Yeah, he can do it.
Jake: Look! He's got those little things to hold.
Jake: Those people that are in there are like "What is happening?"
Jake: Well,
Wren: I can't get up that final 10 percent.
Jake: I'm disappointed.
But you guys-- it was good seeing you guys
But I'll see you guys on Monday
Maybe we can get tacos from the taco truck together.
Wren: So, just come by anytime.
Jake: Is Freddie here?
(Laughter)
(Music)
I threw the ball.
He caught it.
And he threw it back at me
And it was low
So I tried to catch it
And I instinctually put my let out
And it came short and hit me
right above the ankle.
It's alright.
It's just a baseball.
Cameraman: Do you think it's gonna mess up your game?
No
(Laughing)
(Girls Just Wanna Have Fun Playing)
Yeah!
Nice!
Alright, so we're gonna see if Clint's helmet could actually
stop a baseball hit.
Ready?
(Thud)
Clint: Ohh!
(Laughter)
Clint: God!
Clint: Yeah, yeah.
Ow, my hand hurts!
(Car Honking)